hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy
so which methods of glycerophospholipid
synthesis can bacteria or prokaryotes
use well there were two methods one and
two but bacteria prokaryotes can only
use method one can now use method two
and method one basically started with
the CDP daj or the activated
diacylglycerol
which i've drawn here the activated
diacylglycerol i've drawn in a slightly
different way here with the CDP portion
sort of extending out to the right as
opposed to down that might be a little
bit easier to see now how did we get
this we mentioned that we started with
phosphatase and we added to it a CTP and
then a pyrophosphate came off to give us
the CDP daj so what what exactly is
happening here well phosphate a date
already has this phosphate group and
we're adding this purple portion here
that's coming from CTP CTP has three
phosphates two of the phosphates come
off as a pyrophosphate so there's only
one phosphate group left on that and
that basically means that we're adding a
CMP portion to the existing phosphate a
date now what you'll notice is that the
name doesn't seem to imply that right it
says CDP d AG so it sort of can get
confusing because it might make you
think that this in tight like both of
these phosphates came from CTP when they
didn't one of them was already there
from phosphate or should meet one where
the phosphates are already there from
phosphate it ate the red one and the
purple one came from from the CTP so
we're effectively adding a CMP but the
name should still make sense because it
kind of looks like a CDP attached to a
days of Lister also this for the naming
sake it makes sense but the name it
alone could be confusing in allowing you
to understand which parts of this
molecule are coming from what anyway
prokaryotes need to start with this
activated D AG in order to make lists
real phospholipids okay so we mentioned
that glycerophospholipids are made in
four steps
first one is making the backbone the
second one is adding the acyl groups and
to make phosphor today that's basically
the first two steps we saw that already
so especially when we talked about
triglyceride synthesis so up until
faucet today we've basically done steps
1 & 2 so step 3 is adding the the the
polar head groups and in order to do
that we have to activate the da G first
at least in prokaryotes so let's add
these groups so to the left here you'll
see that I'm adding this amino acid this
amino acid is serine and we're
specifically have to add it as an
alcohol right this is the alcohol that
we're adding right this is the polar
head group alcohol that we're adding
here let's see if I can label this in a
let's do orange actually let's do yellow
no let's do pink this is the polar head
group alcohol that we're adding here so
the alcohol specifically that's going to
be connected is right there the o H
group on this area so what's going to
happen is that that part is going to be
attached that's going to actually attack
the phosphate the red phosphate group of
phosphate a day in the in the CDP da G
so this Oasis we connect or this o from
from from this o H is gonna be connected
to this P to give us this molecule here
and so this basically replaces the CMP
portion so the CMP will actually fall
off so the CMP portion falls off and
it's replaced by this serine and so we
get this okay and it might even be a
little bit more helpful to kind of see
this o this o here drawn in this pink
color to show that that oh this is the O
H is connected okay so that gives us
phosphatidylserine
which is basically a glycerophospholipid
that the energy should be the enzyme
that catalyzes this step is called
phosphatidylserine
synthase which makes sense it's making
phosphatidylserine now that is basically
step three right if we think about the
process by which we do this is a step
three we're adding this this alcohol
headed group to make it was real
phospholipid and now we're basically
done right however what can follow is
step four which could include
modifications so we can go from
phosphatidylserine
to phosphatidyl ethanolamine and if you
notice the difference between these two
molecules it's at the head group the
only portion that's different is right
here this carboxyl group is gone right
so phosphatidylserine was decarboxylated
and it lost that carbon dioxide to give
phosphatidyl ethanolamine and that step
was catalyzed by phosphatidylserine
decarboxylase that makes sense
acting on phosphatidylserine and
removing a carboxyl group to give
phosphatidylethanolamine so that would
be basically the step four right the
modification of an existing place for a
phospholipid to give you the final
product okay another case could be
replacing the CMP portion on the CDP da
G with a different alcohol say let's
roll three phosphate and in glycerol
3-phosphate this might be helpful to
sort of track these carbons if we number
these carbons one oops let's do it in
orange if we number them as one two and
three here
which oh wait group is actually going to
be the Oh age group that attaches to the
foot the red phosphate in the CVP da G
well it's going to be the O age group on
carbon number one why is that well first
of all we can see that here in this
because this portion here that was added
the phosphate group is on carbon number
three so this is carbon number three
this is two and this is one that should
be pretty clear from looking at the
molecule but it should also make sense
why this Oh H in particular attacked
it's the least hindered and and it's
away from this negative charge this
negative charge and the negative charge
on this oxygen definitely want to stay
away from each other which makes sense
in the products while I shall fall far
away and this Oh H here is on the end of
this molecule whereas this Oh H is kind
of on the carbon number two is kind of
in the middle of the molecule so carbon
number one gets connected to the Oh over
there and or two that phosphate group
there and now we have phosphatidyl
glycerol 3-phosphate so this is a
glycerophospholipid and again we're
talking about another step three here
and this one is catalyzed by
phosphatidyl glycerol 3-phosphate
synthase again that's it just the name
of the thing that we're making followed
by synthase so now that we have that we
can do wicked we can modify it to give
us a different product to find another
another product and basically what we're
doing here going from foster to glycerol
3-phosphate to foster to the glycerol is
that we're removing this terminal
phosphate out here we're getting rid of
this so how do we get rid of that
well we add faucet to the glycerol
3-phosphate phosphatase which removes
phosphates by hydrolyzing them off so
we'll have h2o and that'll kick off the
phosphate and we'll left off at
phosphatidyl glycerol alright so that
was a modification that gave us this it
can be modified even further in fact we
can add another
phosphatidyl glycerol which I've drawn
here now notice this in purple here is
pretty much identical to this one that's
color-coded a little bit differently
it's got these two acyl groups up here
it's got that and that and then it has
the phosphate with this glycerol portion
out here okay so these molecules are
identical in their overall sort of
schematic and we're going to connect
them and when we connect them this
purple portion of glycerol is actually
going to fall off okay so I'm just going
to write glycerol here to indicate that
this portion here will fall off now I'm
going to draw this one up here a little
bit differently we number these carbons
as one oops in orange as one two and
three earlier just go back and show you
that we did that so down here I'm going
to show it a little bit differently so
those three carbons one two three
instead of drawing them out to the right
like that I'm going to draw them just
down like this 1 2 3 to show that the
phosphate from this phosphatidyl
glycerol that's app coming in it's
adding to this third one this third
carbon and that phosphate is connected
to number three on this glycerol so if I
call this 3 prime 2 prime 1 prime just
to indicate that they're different this
this carbon here is going to be 3 Prime
this is me 2 Prime and 1 Prime and that
should make sense because it might be
confusing just looking at this at first
and seeing that the R 3 is on is on top
r4 is in the bottom and then in the
product where we get this molecule
called cardio life in R 4 is above r3
that might be confusing to people but
it's only confusing if you don't pay
attention to the numbering pattern of
this actual molecule and realize where
the connection is being made but once
you see that it shouldn't be too
difficult to see this molecule
cardiolipin is made by the connecting of
these 2 phosphatidyl glycerols at least
in bacteria by an enzyme cardiolipin
synthase specifically the bacterial
version
and this molecule cardiolipin is an
important component in the inner
mitochondrial membrane as well as
bacterial membranes and it's also
clinically significant because of its
presence in bacterial membranes I'm not
gonna really discuss any of those
details now much figured I'd draw it
because it came up as something that is
clinically significant so I hope that
video was helpful in discussing how
glycerophospholipids are made in
prokaryotes next up is eukaryotes
thank you for watching thanks for
watching don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and be sure to share the video
with anyone who you think might find
helpful thanks and happy studying